- Our daughters are
the same age as I said.
So how is yours handling
school and relationships?
Cuz my daughter it's getting into
mean girls at a very young age.
She's like
this girl's kind of mean,
- [Alyssa] Well.
- and I'm like at seven?
- Girls understand the social structure.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's bizarre.
- [Kelly] It's crazy.
- It's really weird.
And it is, I mean,
this is a hard time to be a parent.
- I think we're all kind of-
- [Kelly] Yeah
- [Kelly] In school and then,
you're at home.
- Well, it's not only that.
It's like, you wanna
terrify them just enough,
that they take-
- Are you a southern mom?
- (laughs) Yeah I think.
That they take care of themselves,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- but also you don't
wanna make them complete,
you know-
- [Kelly] Fearful of everything.
- Yeah, Neurotic,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- and give them anxiety disorders
at seven. So..
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- They have to talk about something
in therapy, Alyssa.
(laughs) So.. I'm kidding.
- [Alyssa] But..
for that to be later,
- [Kelly] I'm just kidding.
No, no.
- Maybe way later it.
- [Kelly] It is a lot.
It is funny.
I don't feel like I felt that weight
when I was her age, and I feel like..
I don't allow mine on social media
or anything, but I feel like
it is a different world though.
Still with the age today
what they're talking about.
- Maybe it's better
that they're understanding
social structure
now-
- [Kelly] Maybe. Yeah.
because of social media-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Rather than later on,
because I don't know
how that's gonna fit into the mix
cuz I don't let them on..
- [Kelly] I don't either.
I'm gonna keep them away
as long as..
They have older siblings.
So that's a little bit
of a problem sometimes,
but it's like, Ooh,
I just want you to stay away
for as long as possible.
- It's a lot.
- It's already hard enough
in person, let alone these trolls at home.
- [Alyssa] I Know.
And I feel so bad for these kids.
I don't know if you've
done the, go back and look
at pictures from before the pandemic,
and how young they were
when this all started-
- My kid,
My five year old boy..
You know how people complain about masks?
He has no idea what a life
is without masks, really.
He doesn't remember..
And he loves it, cuz
he has captain Marvel.
He has all-
- [Alyssa] Right.
- The different masks.
- It's like a uniform, yeah.
- It's like a uniform.
He doesn't even know.
- [Alyssa] Yeah.
- That's kind of cool,
because then you don't have that struggle.
I feel like teens, maybe it's harder,
but the younger ones, they
don't know the difference.
- [Alyssa] I got so sad last night.
I was looking at old pictures,
and I was like-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- This was the good life,
but we didn't know it was the good life.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh, right?
So, you said
intimacy coordinators.
- [Alyssa] Yeah.
- So, what exactly did they do?
- They did..
You know, It was the first time
I ever worked with one, and-
- [Kelly] I Didn't know it was a job.
- It's a job since me too.
And it's so interesting,
because-
- [Kelly] Oh.
- It makes sense because, you know.
If you work with an animal
in a movie, or whatever,
there's someone from the humane society-
- Yeah.
- Standing there,
making sure there's safe and everything.
So the fact that we never had that
for actors or actresses
during these intimate scenes-
- Yeah.
- Was very bizarre,
but they stand there.
They make sure that you're okay.
They have essential oils.
- Wow.
- [Alyssa] They tell you to breathe.
And they're also there
for the crying scenes,
which is really helpful,
because if you're like me..
I have no technique,
so I have to like, to cry,
I have to go into my own trauma.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
That's not great.
- [Alyssa] No, it's, it's not great.
But it was at least more manageable
with an intimacy coordinator,
because they took me into
the trailer afterwards
and they were like, okay, you're done.
You can let that go.
And then I was able to go home,
and be with the kids
and be somewhat not-
- And kind of
compartmentalize that.
- Emotional.
Yeah, not be emotional.
- Oh wow.
- Yeah.
- That is interesting.
I never had anybody on
set with something so..
Like those intimate scenes..
I always wonder with actors,
I'm like, that's awkward.
- [Alyssa] It's well,
kissing scenes are awkward.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Love scenes are awkward.
I mean there's a line
in the movie where
my co-star, Sam page, looks at me
and he is like..
Grace, once isn't gonna be enough.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- And it's-
- [Kelly] First of all,
All right.
- [Alyssa] Yeah.
- (laughs)
- Exactly.
- Fun.
- [Alyssa] And he's so gorgeous,
and that would've been
a really uncomfortable thing,
but we rehearsed it with
this intimacy coordinator.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So we had this beautiful
connection, and it was great.
- [Kelly] That's really cool too,
Keeping everybody comfortable on set too.
Cuz not everybody's comfortable
in that environment, yeah.
- And feeling Protected.
- That's what I mean. Yeah.
- Especially during a love scene.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Is so important.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Yeah.
- And we had a woman director
so we felt very safe, but it was.. Yeah.
- [Kelly] Cool.
- It was definitely an experience
- (laughs) An experience.
- Yeah.
- I'm just gonna think
about that line later today.